you do little tiny quick ones like what
not my prompt its they're called micro
was a way to reverse engineer impression
so they became more interesting like
Sean Connery is being asked whether he
would like to vacation in Spain okay
meter says specifics of his life
Christopher Walken sees a magic trick
wow you know I have a Liam Neeson hold
foods really this is a 10 item or less
line you have 11 items if you leave now
no harm will come to you
you know they can go any any way I do
Tom Brokaw says where is the library in
Spanish oh yeah donde esta biblioteca
they're chewy they're chewy and crunchy
Sanders this is new Bernie Sanders on
the Pirates the Caribbean ride this is
rigged the whole system is rigged the
Pirates are real the Pirates
[Applause]
I love him standing up in the boat
yelling at the Pirates it looks real
that's not Johnny Depp I'm getting an ab
workout you know I do uh what do some of
the other ones I do I do
why do George Bush Senior afraid to go
off the high dive oh yeah Wow there it
is going kind of far down they're not
gonna die you got a mat you got to get
one of those you know who else do I have
in there
I do Michael Cain in kindergarten oh
yeah it's already funny a why do we have
to draw between to launch Jon Lovitz is
a third grader yeah oh you had him at 11
why do we have to use the number three
pencil
the one and only Jon Lovitz
please I hope I have Johnny Carson did I
do this before Johnny Carson getting
pulled over on the for drunk driving in
1975 no oh oh sorry officer I didn't
know I was swerving I had to slippery
monkeys at the hook and crook the entire
joke is the name of the dream yes it is
I had two frozen pillows at the Windy
stomach it's just it's not even alcohol
at that point it's so charming who
wouldn't want to have two slippery
monkeys it I do this is this is 20
seconds it's Al Gore in a new one-man
show called I told you so oh yeah I have
to stand up for this yeah that's fire I
told you I told you I told you we're
getting hot you believe me not the seas
are rising I'm not hypnotizing the ice
is melting we are sweltering we are
getting hot I [ __ ] you know
[Applause]
now everyone says why why are you giving
him that effeminate affectation but I
meet I meet gentleman from Tennessee and
Tennessee gentleman talks like this it
doesn't mean anything about their
sexuality they just have a very
gentlemanly way of going about that talk
I'll just keep what else we got
and then of course your grant is a long
time to Swartz and agar which I
shamelessly I'm gonna doing your
Schwarzenegger now for 24 years
well you've an I do credit you I do say
this is but you've abstracted it yeah
further this Juke it's outer space so
this I'll give you the thing I want you
to do it but I want you cuz you've done
Arnold for many years yeah I want you to
see without hurting yourself yeah blow
it out is far further than Conan ever
had so it's Arnold Schwarzenegger
enjoying a particularly good sandwich
[Applause]
I have a problem I said and not hurt
yourself I know that hurt kind of
well I can't top that was just over much
slower yeah look at the salvage you drop
it and look at the cheese into bread I
eat the sandwich yeah
you